est-ce que vous rappeler le nom de votre
premier amour sceptiques oui c'était
lucy lucy comme en plus il brosse est
non lus ciblant la safim papy brossard
simon recettes ouais ouais c'est quand
il s'appelait s'appelait jean pierre
jean peur si tu nous regardes dollars ou
bien 15 86 ans il a vu mon âge mais je
sais pas elle est notre âge exemplaire
mais c'est sa part il s'appelait comment
gustave mais non mais je crois qu'il
avait le prénom de son grand-père et
s'appelait jean de serres comment il
s'appelait vous annabelle oui c'est
annabelle pardon annabelle à la morgue a
été le balancer son nom de famille mais
alors annabelle duval et bats la pauvre
la plainte
oui c'est vrai vous delphine à la
maternelle il s'appelle kevin away déjà
bah oui le plus tout premier chérissez
wivine kevin je ne sais même plus c'est
vrai qu'à prier galex en partant on va
pas faire tout la version wii pauline
mais elle m'a mis en avant à l'époque
n'en ont parlé sur eux c'est l'époque
des tchats plus à l'école non mais c'est
une victime mais vous savez comment vous
appelez même au niveau des bons moments
en fait on parlait c'était l'époque des
jets y'avait caramel on avait parlé
pendant des mois on était amoureux et un
jour je l'avais ans a rencontré j'avais
ses membres à selma et demi avant elle
m'a dit tu étais trop pas l'avenir il y
avait 13 ans quelques audaces et qui
commence à peine dit pas son nom parce
qu on line chum sont pauline bat pauline
love ckoi et balais pelles et passe à
côté d'un temple
franchement avec une peau magnifique
mais vous avez un épiderme vraiment à
faire pâlir oil of all ages
mais vous ne connaissez pas voilà arthur
pas sinon ça aurait été ballot bah oui
voilà arthur arthur arthur arthur un
autre elle a d'autres et l'applaudît
sympa arthur absolument il apprécia
choron et 6ème et coutainville camero
contacts il aime beaucoup ça a été la
première de tous magnifiques sauf qu
elle faisait était immense
j'étais tout petit mais
j'ai eu beaucoup de bonheur avec el
hatri sachons chanson make up contact
sur instagram est ce qu'elle était très
sympa j'espèrais l'été révèlent même âge
que vous n'en étaient plus âgés que moi
bon non non bien sûr que non mais ses
pairs cas et hong kong
voici la belle est encore là c'est les
autres si vous tapez bambine avait des
taches de rousseur un appareil dentaire
et et un compte ici
non c'est pas vrai c'était on parle pour
le pas du premier animal ou par mail et
[Musique]
et en l'embrassant dit si j bambi merci
gilles verdez nathalie rui je l'aimais
mais elle ne m'aimait pas mal côté c'est
l'histoire de votre vie c'était moi je
m'en rappellerai y avait c'était mélanie
gaudin je croyais me l'avait retrouvée
en plus dans l'émission est tous avec
patrick sabatier web plus tomber qui
sait pas qui fait pas à il fait pas du
tout qui fait pas du tout
malheureusement elle était sortie avec
stéphane galati je veux retrouver je
vais le député je leur promets je vais
le défoncer et steve agathe il avait eu
le coup mais comme à son frère sans
rigoler un arbre et je ne comprenais pas
pourquoi le kif et stepan galati mon
frère je l'embrassé en tout cas stéphane
chabot tu te retrouves est défoncée